Any advice for a grieving parent who lost a child unexpectedly?
Well,
one I would say make sure that you turn to the people that you have left that
you love.
The second I would say is don't be guilty about grieving.
You know,
and if you have friends,
you can tell them,
you could let them do something nice for you because they would like that you
can figure out something they could do that would be nice,
that you would appreciate and let them do it.
Because you know,
other people are going to grieve at some point in the future too.
And maybe they'll be able to ask you for help if you do that.
And then,
well,
I would,
the next thing I would say is give yourself time.
You know,
it takes a year,
maybe longer to adapt,
to adjust even reasonably to such a catastrophic loss.
And then I would say try not to allow that terrible wound to make you bitter
because then not only will you have lost your child and grieve,
but you'll be bitter and then you'll be resentful and then you'll be hateful.
And that'll be like a terrible,
that'll add insult to injury,
so that's too bad.